okay time is short lunches calling joint
work with Josh grotto and Chris more so
we're going to talk about the minimum
circuit size problem a lot of you know
what it is for those of you who don't
you get the entire truth table as input
so it's a bit string of length 2 to the
M along with a number I the question is
does that function have a circuit of
size at most I it's easy to see that
this is in NP and a lot of the interest
in this problem has been because it's
not known or widely believed to be
np-complete a lot of interesting work
has been done and that's not what we're
going to talk about but we are going to
talk about are some of the reasons why
we think it's not in P for instance
factoring would be easy if it were easy
graph isomorphism would be easy more
disturbingly everything is statistical
zero knowledge including anything that's
your favorite crypto problem is bpp
reducible to MC SP and let's pretend for
a little while that actually you really
care about these fine grained notions of
reducibility like what you really want
to know is whether this RP can be
changed to zpp reduction and with that
fiction in mind let's proceed
a problem with this is that throughout
the entire history of the human race
every reduction to MC SP that's tried to
show that this is hard has looked
basically the same and what is that
looking like well minimum circumcised
problem is a great test to distinguish
random strings random distributions from
pseudo-random distributions you know
think about it a small circuit for a
huge truth table is like a short
description of a big string and so it's
no surprise that this is closely related
to a version of time bounded kolmogorov
complexity a pseudo-random the output of
a pseudo random distribution you know
all of that has small kolmogorov
complexity so it's not too much of a
stretch to see that you can distinguish
random from pseudo-random and thus via
hosted in poly also 11 and Looby you can
use it as an Oracle to invert any of
your poly time computable functions most
of the time you know with high enough
probability so what's the point if
you're wanting to give a CPP reduction
using this approach well for zpp you
need a reliable answer from your Oracle
you've got to end up with a proof and if
the only way you're using the Oracle is
to invert functions that means you could
just guess the inverse and so that type
of reduction would give you an NP
intersect Co NP algorithm so you can't
do that for anything that you don't
already know or can't show is in NP
intersect co MP and so in particular for
graph isomorphism we don't know if it's
an NP intersect Co NP so that's a
problem there's another issue with
minimum circuit size problem is that
it's not a single problem it's like a
bunch of problems I didn't say what size
is you could be a number of wires number
of gates you know number of bits you use
to
write down the description in some
standard way and all of these give
different problems and we don't know any
reduction between them you know
everything that we've been able to prove
or anybody's been able to prove till now
for one of these versions holds for any
of the other versions so in that way
it's a meaningful kind of cloud but
nonetheless they're all different
problems and one of the problems in this
cloud is related to this notion of time
bounded kolmogorov complexity so you're
given a string X and a number I you want
to know if it's Katie complexity is it
most I that's the background that's the
context what do we actually do we can
show a graph automorphism is in zpp
relative to this minimum you know this
Katie question so what does that mean it
means that we have a new reduction
finally something new you know
everything earlier has gone through hill
this one doesn't so so that's some
progress what's the problem this is for
this MKT version i happen to love that
but even for me you know who somebody
who cares about time bounded kolmogorov
complexity the main reason I was
interested in it was because you know
it's basically the same thing as the
minimum circuit size problem but here
we've got something we can prove for
this thing in the cloud that we can't
prove for this other you know standard
version of minimum circuit size problem
which is sort of a new phenomenon
everything else that you could do for
for one thing one version of minimum
circuit size you could do for all of the
others what's another thing we can't do
well we can't take a this graph
automorphism result and extend it to
graph isomorphism what we can do and
what's actually the most of the work in
the paper is to take this new reduction
and adapt it to get
instead of a zpp reduction a bpp
reduction which actually is weaker than
we already knew because we know graph
isomorphism has RP reducible to it on
the other hand this is an important
problem minimum circuit size problem has
been studied because it's important and
it's kind of hard to reduce things to it
we've had one hammer and maybe now we
have a hammer and a scalpel or something
I don't know but but it would be good to
build up our tool set so let's actually
do the proof and it's a simple proof
almost embarrassingly simple what we're
going to do is we're going to solve the
graph isomorphism problem restricted to
rigid graphs so this is like the unique
version of graph isomorphism if there's
any isomorphism there's only one because
there are input graphs are you know have
no nontrivial automorphisms so in other
words we're looking at the promised
problem where let's say the yes
instances or where things are isomorphic
the no instances are where things are
rigid and not isomorphic and it might
seem odd that i'm only imposing the
rigidity restriction on the no instances
you know we get the reduction works for
the larger class so you know why not
just use that it actually turns out to
be useful but I won't be able to talk
about that today so how are we going to
do this graph isomorphism is already an
RP relative to this Oracle so we just
need to to do the co RP side and it's
not hard we've got these two graphs as
input g0 g1 we're randomly going to pick
a tea bit string and T permutations and
output this string Z or produce the
string Z which is PI 1 complied to one
of these graphs where the first bit
tells us which one to pick pi 2
applied to one of the graphs and the
second bit tells us which one to pick
etc simple observation if they're not
isomorphic and we're using rigidity in a
big way here then if somebody hands you
Z and you've got all the time in the
world then you can reconstruct PI 1
through PI T as well as these the
individual bits because you know there's
only one possible graph here and one
possible permutation that could have
given you that and similarly so if
somebody hands you see you can
reconstruct all of this randomly chosen
stuff and with high probability we since
you protect big stuff at random that you
know this has got a lot of kolmogorov
complexity and so the amount of
information and there is at least t plus
t s where s is log of n factorial and
otherwise you can describe the sequence
if you know a graph which is M Squared
bits and T permutations so TS what's the
point well if T is a lot more than n
squared then this is enough of a gap
that even with all the slop and the fact
that I'm lying about some stuff to
simplify things you can just ask is the
KT complexity above that threshold or
below and with high probability you'll
get the right answer and that's it that
is the entire proof why doesn't this
work for minimum circuit size the
easiest way that I can explain this to
you is to give a sort of bogus circuit
model there's not bogus it's creative a
creative circuit model where in fact the
proof does go through I also need to
remind you since I'm some of you might
have forgotten exactly how katie is
defined this funny time bounded
kolmogorov complexity measure is the
minimum of the length of the description
plus the running time such that our
universal machine can construct
x from the description d in time T and
your initial reaction might be X's and
bits so it's always going to take time n
to do this and the way we get around
that is to actually do things bitwise so
more formally some of the length of the
description plus the running time says
that if our universal machine as random
access to D that's why it's written like
an Oracle and we're given number I we
can figure out what the i'th bit of X is
and the whole thing doesn't take time
more than T so what's the circuit model
let's say that a circuit a multiplexer
circuits got the usual and or and not
gates as well as some fixed array of M
bits and you've got index get gates with
fan and log M so if they have wires that
evaluate to I that tells you what the
eighth bit of the array is and if you do
that model of circuits then in fact
everything goes through because this
model can simulate that machine you
pretty efficiently namely you distort
the description in that array but if you
just want to use circuits that people
actually care about like and or not
gates well to implement a multiplexer
for an array of size M you need like
order M bits and you need that for each
query that you make to the description
and it just kills everything you know
you get no information so
it means that I don't know that for the
no instances the complexity is actually
different than the complexity for the
yes instances you know basically idea I
get no information you know it breaks
everything so naturally what you might
want to do is to sort of get amplify
this gap and if you could do this you
know that this gap in complexity or gap
and circuit size if you could do this I
think that would actually be really
interesting and a more important
contribution than what I'm talking about
because it would at least show that for
certain gap versions of these minimum
circuit size problems which are the only
versions anybody ever actually uses that
you could actually maybe reduce them to
each other instead of having them all be
these unrelated cloud of problems and
that's I think something that would
really give some some robustness to this
whole theory I mean right now there's
lots of papers written about minimum
circuit size as if that was a meaningful
independent notion but actually you know
I wrote this question up as I was flying
out here and so maybe there's a reason
why this is not really an open question
but as far as I know you could take two
of your favorite versions of minimum
circuit size and maybe one of them is in
P and the other one is np-complete and p
is not equal to NP you know is there a
reason why this can't happen I don't
know of it so you know this funny thing
about MKT having a proof that goes
through there but not for ordinary
minimum circuit sighs honestly I think
it's probably just because we were too
dumb to figure out how to do the
appropriate gap amplification or come up
with a different argument but but for
now it's it's possible that the
the complexity could be wide open so to
close one open question is replace this
Katie problem with your usual MC SP do
something better with graph isomorphism
or maybe you know put all of statistical
zero knowledge and zpp relative to this
Oracle and more fundamentally is there
some way to relate the complexities of
these different versions of minimum
circuit size and yeah any way at all so
good have lunch I think your your
question about amplification might be
even more interesting design questions
about the complexity of minimum friction
sighs problem because what was such a
reduction be of the construction that
given a buoyant pumpkin app and sort of
conjecture size gives you another
function of time where you know you know
like if there's some guy saying either
this has heart is hard or easy then this
other function you have a wider gap
between the hardness yeah but maybe you
know the way to do that would be either
this is hard or easy and this one you
know just lower everything but have a
bigger gap I think it would be great too
but you know it's more plausible than
trying to get something that's harder
than what you started with one reason I
leave in lowering the lowering the range
but
really interested like about a colleague
at UCSD he said I'm never gonna like
encrypt my dad because I know I'm going
to lose my key and never going to be
able to decrypt it's all gonna be like
make my dad a secure by any reasonable
means you know I might do it if I knew
exactly the threshold where I could
reconstruct it if I really needed to but
it would still be at least moderately
secure so say we've got like a really
hard problem can we make it can we move
it to a control problem where we have a
plain brain understanding know exactly
how r it is but I kind of moving to
something that you just know is within a
big broad ring or something work we know
the complexity is it up to within about
20 rings really
what he said yeah the questions okay
let's thank Eric and